apparently the very cool in my opinion
Starfield collector edition watches are
already breaking the game has only been
out for a month which means they've only
been in use for a month and while they
do again look awesome I have an unboxing
here on my channel I thought it was
absolutely gorgeous they can't be easy
to fix being that they came in limited
collector editions and you can't just
like go into an Apple store customer
reports have people saying that they
have been speaking to customer service
but no suggestions or Solutions have
been offered that have actually worked
and that refunds are not available I
guess especially considering everything
else in the collector edition is still
fine just not the very expensive watch
there are a bunch of posts about this on
Reddit and it seems like people are
trying to band together to get some
actual help from Bethesda so if you are
looking for some help for this I would
recommend checking out that community